hello good afternoon and welcome to the
Barnes & Noble Naperville today Neil
Dahlstrom joins us to prevent details
into Lincoln's relationship with the
press and to sign copies of his newest
book Lincoln xerath Lincoln's wrath
tells the dramatic tale of Abraham
Lincoln's war against the press and the
small town publisher who risked
imprisonment to protect free speech Neal
Dahlstrom a noted historian and scholar
has published more than 20 articles on
nineteenth-century American history
including the Civil War he is the
co-author of the John Deere story a
biography of plow makers John and
Charles dear mr. Dahlstrom co-authored
Lincoln's wrath with Jeffrey Mann burr
c-span is here today so once the floor
is open to discussion please raise your
hand so that we may bring a microphone
to you when you ask your question thank
you and please welcome me in joining
Neil Dahlstrom
well thank you very much everybody for
being here and braving a typical Chicago
winter day I'm delighted to be here and
I'm very excited to talk about Lincoln's
wrath fierce mobs brilliant scoundrels
and a president's mission to destroy the
press and that taught that that title is
really a mouthful but I'm gonna explain
how all those pieces kind of fit in here
my involvement in this book started
about six years ago and my co-author
Jeff remember had already been working
on the project for about four years and
this started innocently enough as
stories like this often do he was
watching the news and he saw a report
about censorship of the press they
happen to mention censorship during the
Civil War and this is something that
Jeffery always had an interest in and he
was always looking at the political side
of the Civil War so this really piqued
his interest from there he went to his
local library
he ended up finding an article published
in the 1960s on a copperhead newspaper
editor by the name of John Hodgson and
this was about a 20 page article and a
really intrigued Jeff this was one man
who was standing up against the Lincoln
administration for his right to write
opposition pieces
the Civil War four years later I come
along and Jeff asked me to join the
project and I'd had a background in
Civil War Civil War reenactors in high
school working in museums and Civil War
was always my interest and always my
fascination and I was attracted to John
Hodgson of course as we got into this
story this great Civil War story
you're always led to Abraham Lincoln the
buck always stops with Abraham Lincoln
when you're talking Civil War and
growing up in Illinois spending my
childhood on summer vacations with the
family going to Springfield I like so
many of us idolized Abraham Lincoln and
we always put him on this pedestal well
as we continue to get deeper into this
research my views on Abraham Lincoln
started to change a little bit and I'm
always interested talking to people
after they read the book or even just
when they read the title I had a young
lady come up to me about three weeks ago
at a book signing and she was very timid
and she was kind of standing off to the
side and she kind of worked her way over
and she finally came up to me and she
said I need to buy a book for my
grandfather and he loves Abraham Lincoln
and he's a die-hard Republican does this
bash Abraham Lincoln because if it does
I can't buy this book and I'm sorry I
don't mean to offend you and of course I
said no I'm not offended by that and our
intention is not to bash Abraham Lincoln
our intent was to research a story from
the other side of things often when you
read a traditional Lincoln biography or
a traditional civil war story what
you're going to find is and everything
else are talking about with Lincoln and
his administration and how he persecuted
the war you may find a paragraph or two
that says yes Lincoln suspended habeas
corpus he declared martial law there
were other issues constitutional issues
that maybe he looked at in a different
way he stretched the elasticity of the
Constitution and then they move on to
the rest of the story well what we
wanted to do with this story is take
that paragraph or two and turn it in to
Lincoln's wrath we wanted to know what
it was like to be on the other side of
this story we
wanted to know what it was like to be
someone who was persecuted by the
Lincoln administration who was
threatened by local mobs who was
threatened by politicians who saw fellow
editors and and Democratic politicians
thrown in prison for a month six months
or a year we wanted to know how it
affected their families how it affected
their lives and the courage it took to
stand up to a president during wartime
who was threatening their rights as
American citizens John Hudson is a
newspaper editor in Westchester
Pennsylvania just outside of
Philadelphia and he is a journalist in
every sense of the word he believes he
hid his great idol is Thomas Jefferson
he's a strong believer in states rights
and he believes that the federal
government really has no right to
intrude on the rights of the states and
of the individual and he's writing about
this in his newspapers on a daily basis
and this period in time is really the
rise of the modern newspaper but
newspapers during this time are strictly
political organs in 1860 there's about
3,500 newspapers in the United States
population of roughly 30 million people
and according to the census at least 95%
of these are political in nature
newspapers were Republican or they were
democratic there wasn't such a thing as
a conflict of interest there wasn't
newspaper editors trying to be impartial
or objective they were what they were
there to support a political party John
hodgson was no different he was a
lifelong Democrat and he stood for
everything the Democratic Party believed
in whether he always agreed with it or
not
that included things like the
continuation of slavery he didn't think
the Republican Party had any business
trying to end the institution of slavery
and that's going to come out in his
editorials the country of course leading
up to the Civil War everybody seemed to
see this coming and with the election of
Abraham Lincoln in November of 1860 that
was the breaking point but Hodgson like
most Easterners had an earlier
introduction to Abraham Lincoln
in February of 1869 canoes really
introduced to the east through an
address he gives at Cooper Union in
Manhattan this speech is reprinted by
local newspapers it's distributed in
pamphlet form and Lincoln that morning
went to Mathew Brady's studio and got
his picture taken
so not only are folks finally introduced
to the words of this possible
presidential candidate but they see him
for the first time and Lincoln we call
Lincoln the first media president and
Lincoln was very adept at manipulating
the press for his own political
advantage and he proves his time and
again leading up to his nomination and
then before the war and then throughout
the war he shows his time and again
before he arrives at Manhattan to give
this speech he's introduced in a local
newspaper in Westchester of all places a
town of 5,000 people this came through a
series of friends and associates a
former Westchester resident who had
moved to Illinois John Hutchins reads
this biographical commentary on Abraham
Lincoln written of course by Lincoln
himself Hutchins has an instant hatred
for Abraham Lincoln he's a Republican
you know one strike against you of
course and that's really all I needed to
know when it come when it came to
Abraham Lincoln so from there Hutchins
is is spewing off these commentaries
like the election of Lincoln will be the
death knell to the Republic and he truly
believes this and he's writing this up
to the nomination and of course after
the election of Lincoln things get even
worse Lincoln gives his inaugural
address in March of 1861 and Hatchin
calls it a lame and unsatisfactory
affair and this is really light-hearted
stuff for John Hodgson
he's a sensationalist editor he's he's
racist he's a bigot he's the type of
person that you would not want to be
associated with today he was he had a
violent temper but he had a loyal
following and he was using this to his
advantage to support the Confederacy
during the war of course Hodgson didn't
flee South he stayed in the north as
thousands of what's called the law
opposition in these newspapers do and
that's what this story's about a wave of
events begins to occur just before the
war breaks out Lincoln has problems in
Baltimore there's a riot in Baltimore as
Lincoln's trying to bring troops into
Washington DC of course poor Sumpter's
fired on in April of 1861 the war
officially commences meanwhile John
Hodgson is involved in a barroom brawl
in Westchester because he's denouncing
Abraham Lincoln in the Republican Party
we know about this because there's a
broadside that's published by a rival
newspaper later that week and they give
a full accounting of secessionist versus
Republican everyone's out to get John
Hodgson in Westchester a young man
writes a letter to his mother around the
same time that says John Hutchins is
going to be hung I was going to say
mobbed I will John Hutchins office isn't
going to stand long unless he dries up
so everyone's talking about John hodgson
in Westchester and he's making a lot of
enemies is the point the nature of the
Union starts to change after the riots
in Baltimore Lincoln has to act
unilaterally he suspends habeas corpus
which he gets into a lot of trouble with
the the Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court over this but he's trying to fight
off the war early on he calls Congress
into a special session which convenes on
July 4th 1861 and runs for about a month
ends on August 6 and this Congress comes
into session as the first Republican
Congress in US history and they decide
early on they're only going to pass laws
that have to do with fighting the war
and believe it or not they passed 67
public laws in a month imagine Congress
today actually passing 67 public laws
they may give us what a half dozen to a
dozen in a year so this is a
quick-moving Congress and they're saying
things like give the president three
million men right off the bat because
this is going to be a short war and
we're gonna take advantage of it and
we're going to win this thing and stamp
it out early on
things don't go that way but something
pivotal happens on the last day of this
special session of Congress Congress has
been talking back and forth about the
confiscation of property and one of the
things that they're looking at of course
are slaves if a slave makes it to the
north they want to be able to seize that
as contraband and free that slave they
also want to suppress anyone who's using
property in the north to support the
Confederacy aiding and abetting the
enemy and on August 6th Congress passes
the Confiscation Act
Lincoln signs the bill he's kind of
hesitant when he signs this but he
thinks it's necessary necessary to curb
dissent during the war and this plays
out for John Hodgson what this Act does
in essence is give US Marshals and other
local officials the power to confiscate
any property they deem is being used to
support the Confederacy we don't have
any evidence that this was meant to
include newspapers but this is quickly
what developed you have politicians and
editors working hand in hand as I said
all newspapers are political in nature
you're not going to find a successful
politician without a successful editor
standing behind them and vice versa
Lincoln had his favorite editors John
Hutchins had his favorite politicians
and there was a lot of money to be made
the Confiscation Act also allowed
editors and politicians to make a lot of
money and to maybe settle old scores
take care of old enemies in the process
within the fog of war and this is what
begins to take place in the summer of
1860 61 what we call the summer of rage
the mobs become rampant in August the
three-month enlistments are up soldiers
start coming home and of course people
want to support the troops even if they
don't support the war but that's not
always the case folks like John hatch
and they're not supporting either and
this is angering people so the mobs
begin to take to the street if you're
going to publish an editorial that says
Lincoln's wrong the persecution of the
war is wrong
this is the second American Revolution
and the South should be allowed to go
well pretty soon you're probably going
to have a mob on your door and that's
what happened on August 19th 1861 and
this is coming from a politician Edward
Everett who just recently run for vice
president of the United States he
publishes a letter in a New York
newspaper which says in essence the
government is moving way too slow and
because the government's moving too slow
we're going to lose this war the mobs
need to take these newspapers down just
just imagine today if if the governor
made a call that said well the police
force I don't think is going to take
care of it so we need citizens to light
their torches and walk down the streets
and start burning vehicles and start
burning newspaper offices so that they
can't publish this is exactly what's
happening in the United States in 1861
people taking to the streets as I said
John Hodgson knew it was coming and it
finally comes for him on August 19th
it's a Monday night it's the same day
that that letter is published in a New
York paper January of that year John
Hutchins he was he he liked to bring
these things upon himself he was very
arrogant in this way and he was warned
at a bipartisan meeting at one point and
in his paper the next day he says well
if the mobs do come I at least hope
they'll have the courage to do it during
the daytime when I can be there and I
can watch well that doesn't really turn
out that way instead the mobs visit in
the middle of the night they throw the
printing presses out of the windows they
rip up the subscription list it's a
complete destruction of the property of
course Hodgson arrives the next day
completely furious this is where the
story would stop for most editors in the
North when the mobs attacked and either
destroyed their office maybe the editor
was tarred and feathered maybe he was
ridden on rail on a rail through town
they would maybe stop publication they
would decide to maybe become a little
more sympathetic
to the war effort or they would run they
would go north they would go south John
hodgson is not every other editor he
decides he's going to put out his next
issue of the Jeffersonian that Saturday
so he spends a week traveling to
Philadelphia to utilize the presses of
another newspaper and this is where this
story really begins to get interesting
John Hutchins running back and forth
he's going to print this newspaper of
course denouncing the acts of the
Lincoln administration denouncing the
acts of the mob he's also going to print
a special broadside denouncing all these
sorts of things but when he returns to
Westchester on Friday August 23rd
something very very unique happens the
confiscation act comes into play he'd
been utilizing the presses of the
Christian Observer he leaves for the day
has the paper put the bed hops on a
train to return to Westchester as he
does Philadelphia marshals stormed the
office of the Christian Observer
meanwhile in Westchester where his son
is working to get the paper back up and
running
US Marshals visit the Jeffersonian and
they give his son a warrant that says
under authority of the President of the
United States were confiscating this
office because it's being used to
support the Confederacy of course John
Hutchins is absolutely furious he's told
to appear in court in a few months which
he does surprisingly enough the district
attorney doesn't even make an appearance
and the case is dropped John Hodgson's
trying to figure out what in the world
is going on obviously they're trying to
censor me they don't want me to publish
I haven't put out a paper in two months
because of the seizure of the property
and John Hutchins decides to do
something he decides to turn the tables
and he decides to sue the United States
government and this is just unheard of
at the time when all the other editors
are turning tail and running John
Hutchins decides to stand up so the
courage of this man is something that
was just mind-boggling to me as we
continued to research this story and
this is where a lot of these brilliant
scoundrels and the book start to make
their appearance these are people that
you absolutely just want to hate and
despise because the things that they
believe in are just are just terrible
but they're fighting for the right thing
they're fighting for their right to
speak out they're fighting for their
First Amendment right so even though we
despised John Hodgson we found ourselves
gravitating towards him and the things
that he was standing up for and fighting
for the district attorney who didn't
make his appearance in court suggested
to John Hodgson that he does find an
attorney and of course offers one up and
John Hutchins no dummy if the district
attorney who just signed the papers to
seize all of your properties it
recommends an attorney you're going to
turn him down and you're going to find
your own John hodgson finds two of the
most famous attorneys in Pennsylvania
William Bradford Reid and George
Washington Biddle both with
Revolutionary War ties William Bradford
Reid's grandfather was George
Washington's private secretary during
the Revolutionary War another one of
those interesting ties of the Civil War
period these people remember the Civil
War general Usha nari Ward generation
because their grandfathers were there
and their grandfathers talked about it
when they were growing up Reid is a is a
southern sympathizer he left the United
States just before the war broke out
because he was afraid for his life and
he returned in early 1861 and he begins
publishing pamphlets anonymously because
he doesn't want word to get out that
he's actually publishing this material
he decides to come out this is his
coming out party he decides to take this
case because this case is this important
to him meanwhile John Hodgins trying to
figure out why other editors are being
thrown in prison while other edit why
other editors are being tarred and
feathered and why why he's being allowed
to prosecute this case
and this is one of those strange
paradoxes of of this story other editors
are thrown in prison Frankie Howard in
Baltimore is arrested in September of
1861 and he spends 13 months in prison
he's never charged with a crime and he's
released just all of a sudden and
doesn't know why obviously it's because
of the editorials he's writing in
opposition to the
war from what we can tell the
administration's trying to bite I and
they're succeeding so far but there's a
change going on in the north while all
this is going on
John Hodgins case is finally going to
come in March of 1863 so it's about 19
months after these initial events take
place for him but there's a change going
on northerners are starting to get fed
up with the war everyone thought this
was going to be a 90-day war and now the
realities are setting in their sons are
dying their husbands their fathers their
brothers are dying and this war is going
to see over 600,000 casualties before
before all said and done and the war
ends in 1865 so the realities are really
setting in and they're looking for a
change and in 1862 the Democrats start
taking political power back they win
governorships Lincoln loses his own
congressional district in Illinois to a
Democrat in late 1862 and 8th and in
early 1863 these folks are starting to
take office a gentleman in New Jersey by
the name of James wall his house is
broken into and late 1861 he's tackled
to the ground he's dragged out he's
thrown in prison for two weeks for
editorials that he had written in a New
York newspaper he's elected to Congress
in 1862 so you have this amazing change
taking place in the American landscape
John Hodgins looking to Abraham Lincoln
as the source of this the direct tie is
the warrant served on his office says
this property is confiscating
confiscated under authority of the
President of the United States so this
is where he's looking as the ultimate
source of his suppression but there's
other players involved and John Hodgson
starts locally he starts with someone
who's who he grew up with but has had a
bitter feud with for the last oh just
maybe four or five years
a congressman by the name of John
Hickman John Hickman was a loyal
Democrat his entire career
he'd spent three terms in Congress as a
loyal Democrat but as the war approached
he changed his loyalties and became a
Republican and he became a die-hard
Lincoln supporter he becomes one of
these Radical Republicans in Congress
when Congress says someone stands on the
floor of the house and says we need to
raise 500,000 men Hickman stands up and
says we need to raise twice 500,000 men
we need to raise four million men and
any amount of money possible to
persecute this war once again he's a
Republican John Hodgman hates his guts
and there's a lot of backstory with that
ironically enough John Hudson had been
sued for libel in the late 1840s and the
attorney who defended his case was John
Hickman so they had these ties so you
have these wonderful ironies coming out
during the course of this story of
course a successful politician John
Hickman has a loyal editor by his side a
guy by the name of John Forney editor
and founder of the Philadelphia press
and recently the Washington Chronicle
when the war starts he moves to
Washington and he opens the Washington
Chronicle which is a weekly paper
Abraham Lincoln comes to him and asks
him to turn this into a daily paper
which he does in early 1862 and this is
a newspaper that sent out amongst the
troops this is Lincoln's vehicle for
communicating with the soldiers in the
field I mentioned earlier that this is a
time where conflicts of interest really
didn't exist not only is John Forney
editor of the press and the Washington
Chronicle
he's also Secretary of the House of
Representatives a position gotten for
him by Abraham Lincoln he had previously
been secretary of the Senate so you have
these newspaper editors who are really
in large part running the show either
behind politicians or their politicians
themselves Forney's kind of considered
the social director of Washington DC
during the war another editor at one
time calls him Lincoln's dog so they
have these great terms that they use for
each other John hodgson calls Forney and
Hickman the Twin renegades and he's
always referring to Hickman & Company in
his newspaper saying Hickman and company
is responsible for the mob visiting my
newspaper office for the confiscation of
the office
but there's other methods the
administration uses and this is one of
the interesting things about Lincoln's
cabinet is they were very disorganized
throughout the war in 1861 William
Seward the the Secretary of State and
Simon Cameron the Secretary of War are
bickering over who's responsible for
domestic arrests its time of war so that
needs to go to the Secretary of War
so it says we'll know its domestic it's
on the homefront so I'm responsible for
this so there's a lot of confusion
there's a lot of local officials looking
to make a name for themselves in taking
advantage of the situation and all this
falls on folks like John Hodgson when he
does begin reprinting his paper after
that Circuit Court case in October of
1861 he's anxious he's going to get his
first issue out on October 26th and they
deliver the newspaper to the post office
well new news for John Hudson the
Postmaster General has banned his
newspaper from the u.s. mail system so
he now he has no way to distribute this
newspaper
of course John Hudson's getting angrier
and angrier and angrier his editorials
show it and I would love to read you
some of his editorials we talked of
obviously we print a lot of them in the
book but they're things I really don't
feel comfortable saying all the time
because it's really heated stuff
definitely not things that you would get
away with in the newspaper today or
certainly not on TV so I'll let you read
those on your own but it's really
powerful stuff and this is an age where
people expected to open up a newspaper
and read a three-page speech from their
local congressman because they weren't
interested in reading the box scores you
know this is their their news was what
their politicians were doing so a very
very different time in that respect so
we're working through 1862 the Democrats
are starting to regain power and things
are starting to go their way especially
in Philadelphia the Democrats are really
at the height of their power they
established a new democratic newspaper
they established a new Club where
they're holding meetings in Independence
Square William Bradford Reid and George
Washington Biddle Hodgson's attorneys
are leading these
huge demonstrations through Philadelphia
really stirring things up people are
writing in their diaries that that
they're afraid that the entire city is
going to be put under federal control
and that they're gonna wake up every day
and there's going to be Union soldiers
guarding their homes because they don't
know how this is going to go and
remember they don't know how this war is
going to turn out and so this is a very
scary time we see images today in the
Middle East and on other sides of the
world where there's demonstrations
people taking to the streets torching
cars and homes this is what's going on
in Philadelphia and throughout the north
during the Civil War so this is outside
of your front window and you're afraid
to speak out because you're afraid this
mob is gonna come tear down your home
tear down your livelihood so this is a
very real thing and they don't know how
this is going to turn out but they do
have elections and this is where people
are using their power average American
citizens are going to the ballot box and
Lincoln says this early on he says we
have to win this war to prove that
you're not going to change things with
bullets ballot boxes are the places to
make change and that's what we're going
to prove and again another one of the
great ironies of this story is that
holds up elections are held on schedule
throughout the north and John Hutchins
does receive his day in court in March
1863 of course the newspapers are
climbing all over themselves to cover
this story John Forney and his
Philadelphia newspaper the press is
saying all sorts of things about the
attorneys that they're just a completely
disgraceful affair they're secessionists
and we shouldn't listen to them they're
going to single-handedly destroy this
country and they're going to
single-handedly bring down the Lincoln
administration so you have all this
coming to this dramatic climax in March
of 1863 but it comes down to a courtroom
in Philadelphia the Philadelphia Supreme
Court presiding over by Chief Justice
walter Lowery and twelve average
Americans that's not a term I use a lot
I don't know if there's necessarily an
average American but if
these are the average Americans of the
Civil War time there's a butcher there's
a farmer there's a shoemaker not a
candlestick maker as far as I know but
these are these are these average
Americans who are called in to pass
judgment on this case they listen to the
opening arguments and the newspapers are
reprinting these arguments the next day
in their newspaper because people want
to know what's going on on the third day
the jury comes back having heard judge
Lowery's verdict over the case and he
makes amazing an amazing charge to the
jury he tries to figure out if there's a
paper trail that says that Abraham
Lincoln ordered the seizure of this
newspaper or not this is the important
case they're discussing the merits of
the Confiscation Act does Congress have
the right to seize the property of
American citizens during wartime is it
necessary to have a warrant and if those
things occur then there has to be a
paper trail this can't be something that
people do arbitrarily because they're
afraid of what's happening what's being
said things that sound very familiar
today right so these are very timeless
timeless words that Judge Lowery is
speaking to this jury and in essence the
conclusion he comes to and and the
decision that he puts on this jury is
that does the president have the power
to do this during the war time does it
does the president have the power to
overstep the bounds of the Constitution
and to suppress the press during wartime
and this is what he leaves for this
12-man jury now we've gone this far I've
set up this story you can understand why
we titled this book
Lincoln's wrath and this is a title I
absolutely love because I think this is
a this this is a title that John Hodgson
would have written he would have loved
that the the phrase Lincoln's wrath and
this is really what I like about
the title and what I like about the book
because we tried to make these
characters come alive I'm not going to
give the end of the story away because
that really wouldn't be any fun when we
get to the end of this but this is what
we're left with in March of 1863 we all
know how the war ends up
we know that the Union wins one of the
issues that John Hutchins battling in
his editorials as he says whenever in
history have our civil liberties been
taken away and then restored when the
war was over and that's a question that
we have today we don't know when the war
on terror is going to end so if we
remove civil liberties in any way when
are they ever going to be returned and
this is what bothered John Hutchins the
most and he was scared of things like
the centralization of the federal
government Lincoln was doing insane
things according to John Hutchins like
printing federal currency who's ever
heard of a federal currency you know
we've used Pennsylvania notes and we've
used Vermont notes who needs a federal
currency who needs federal holidays we
don't need a centralized government and
these are the things that John Hodgson's
fighting for and in the end he's
fighting for his right to say these
things whether he's right or wrong and
these are things that might my co-author
Jeff remember and I to this day disagree
about and we say this in the
introduction ten years of research and
writing and discussing this book and we
disagree on whether Lincoln was right
and what he did to suppress civil
liberties during the Civil War and I
would challenge each of you as you read
through the book to think about that was
Lincoln right and are we better for
today or we worse for it today and when
I started talking I said that I'd always
idolized Abraham Lincoln I always put
him on a pedestal and I think often
scholarship tends to do that we
gravitate towards that because that's
the familiar that's what we know about
Abraham Lincoln but there's all these
amazing stories that make that up and I
think when you get to the root of all
these stories you see a very different
side of Abraham Lincoln you see a very
different side of the United States of
America
during the Civil War and I think that
can't help but maybe alter the way you
think about things today and I think
that's all for the better I think I'm
gonna wrap up there and thank you all
for listening and I'm happy to answer
any questions that you have thank you
yes you disagree with the author and
whether Lincoln was right and which side
do you fall do you think he was right or
do you think he was wrong I tend to give
Abraham Lincoln the benefit of the doubt
more than Jeffery would I guess I have a
more conservative view Lincoln's
fighting an unprecedented war when the
war erupted Congress was not in session
he really didn't have anyplace to turn
and there was a lot of cabinet
infighting no one thought that Lincoln
even deserved to be in the White House
Seward considered himself kind of a the
Prime Minister of the United States that
Lincoln's going to fail and I'm going to
be able to take control this whole thing
pretty soon so as far as that goes I
tend to give Lincoln the benefit of the
doubt because he's in the room and he's
the guy having to make the tough
decisions where that starts to fall
apart a little bit for me it's through
the course of the war because Lincoln
knows that these things are taking place
and whether or not he's actually signing
the document that says yes seize this
newspaper or don't seize this newspaper
he knows this is going on because we
know that the wives of prisoners are
coming to the White House and they're
visiting Lincoln and they're saying our
husbands have been arrested and we don't
know why what's going on and Lincoln
says I'll go talk to Seward I'm pretty
sure he probably ordered it or go talk
to Cameron so I tend to look a little
more negatively and I would agree with
Jeff a little more as the war progresses
but I I look at how Lincoln approached
civil liberties the same way that he he
approached slavery and the way a
pro-slavery was if I can win the war by
freeing none of the slaves I'll do it if
I can win the war by freeing all the
slaves I'll do it and I think he looked
at censorship in the same way if I have
to censor the press to win then I'm
gonna have to do that because if I don't
then what's the point we lose and all
this is lost Jeff on the other hand
would say civil liberties are sacred
constitutional right and you can't touch
him for anything and the Constitution
says so that's a short version of Jeff's
argument yes you and your co-author
disagreed has that caused any problems
writing the book or have you guys sort
of happily agreed to disagree or you
know two heads are better than one what
how did that work out in the end now
that the books out I'll say we happily
disagree that wasn't always the case
there's you know it's interesting when
you when you co-write a book to begin
with because you have different writing
styles you have different research
styles it adds a lot to the book because
you're looking at perspectives that
maybe you wouldn't have looked at on
your own but there were heated
discussions we we I remember sitting
there with a big dry erase board writing
down ideas and we would write something
Jeff would write something down and I'd
say no that's terrible that doesn't have
anything to do with the story and he'd
say this is the point of the story so in
the beginning we were trying to decide
is this a book about Abraham Lincoln or
is this a book about John Hudson
and when we got down to it we said this
is John Hodgson's story and as
historians were the vehicle to tell that
story and we don't feel it's our place
to tell our readers if John Hudson was
right or if John Hodgman was wrong and
if Lincoln was right or wrong but we
wanted to tell the story from a
contemporary point of view what was it
like to be there of course there's
there's those squabbles over what needs
to be there and what doesn't need to be
there but we work through all that and
we came to a medium and sometimes a Jeff
would include something and I knew that
I needed to fight against it and he
would say the same thing about me so we
think the books stronger because of that
though thank you very much thank you
you mentioned that some of the other
newspaper editors ended up being
arrested to what extent like how many of
these editors ended up being arrested
was it just a few or a good number well
we know there were at least 12,000
political arrests during the war these
are politicians newspaper editors and
others we don't have a full count of how
many were just editors it was probably
in the hundreds but it's really amazing
you you had Lincoln having to make
decisions like in Baltimore in September
I mentioned Frankie Howard earlier
Frankie Howard is the grandson of
Francis Scott Key and he's arrested as
part of a dragnet that arrests I think
13 individuals that includes state
legislators that includes a US
congressman who happens to sit on the
House Judiciary Committee with John
Hickman and it includes several editors
and local attorneys and the reason they
were arrested is because there was going
to be a vote in the state legislature
force discussing whether or not they
were going to Baltimore well excuse me
Maryland was going to secede from the
union there had already been a vote
earlier in the year and they voted not
to secede but Lincoln was terrified that
Maryland was going to secede from the
union and so instead of letting that
election take place or that vote take
place they decided to arrest the
opposition
Frankie Howard when he got out of prison
he wrote about a hundred page pamphlet
called thirteen months an American
Bastille and this is what what folks
like John Hudson were calling northern
prison camps they're calling him
American Bastille and he writes in there
that it didn't escape his attention that
he was arrested on the anniversary that
his grandfather wrote the star-spangled
banner from outside of Fort McHenry the
very prison he was sitting in at that
very moment so there were thousands of
arrests for political purposes during
the war and and like I said these are
folks that the newspapers called the
loyal opposition these are people who
didn't necessarily always support the
Confederacy but they supported the
Confederacy's right to lead the Union
yes sir a cabinet that he would never
have the politician today wouldn't have
and that many of the members were
actually rivals of his political rivals
at least a couple of them had
aspirations of the presidency themselves
didn't get the nomination and really
kind of wanted him to fail in terms of
the conduct of the civil war I'm just
wondering if you don't think that this
had a bearing on some of these decisions
he made in regards to writing his
confiscation you know agreeing to the
confiscation Act I'm thinking that the
president really had nobody to turn to
great little help and the decisions of
this magnitude III think that that it
did play a role but I think Lincoln
shows himself during the good during the
course of the war he kind of gets more
comfortable in his own skin but I think
he shows himself early on as someone who
is gonna really take in what everybody
else has to say but he's the president
and regardless of whether anybody else
really wants to wants to accept that
early on he knows that he's the one
making the decisions and he accepts
responsibility for those decisions
another interesting thing about
Lincoln's cabinet and something that
John Hodgson definitely knew was that
most of Lincoln's cabinet members they
were either former editors themselves or
they owned newspapers so when Hodgins
looking at what he considers to be a
conspiracy between Hickman and Forney
and probably the president the cabinet's
included in that and he's trying to
figure out maybe are they going to make
a little money on the side because of
this because if Hodgson and his fellow
Democratic editors are shut down
someone's going to pick up the patronage
because Hodgson has five or six thousand
subscribers they need a new newspaper to
subscribe to and in Westchester town of
5,000 people there's five newspapers
four Republican and one Democrat so when
that Democratic newspaper disappears
those people have to read something so
there's a lot of money to be made
and Hodgins trying to figure out well as
Simon Cameron who who is tied to the the
evening bulletin in Philadelphia does he
have something to do with this because
he's going to make a lot of money and
everyone knows that Simon Cameron
Cameron is a scoundrel and and that's
why Lincoln and essent fires him the
following year and replaces him so the
cabinet definitely played a major role
but but the decision came down to
Lincoln
um looking back now you can see that
this is really dealing with some major
First Amendment issues but in your
research were you able to get a sense of
just how much play this was getting in
the press at the time other than by Hadj
them and hypes animals himself it was
being talked about everywhere and you
know it's amazing when we started this
ten years ago of course we thought First
Amendment issues are always relevant
this is an important story and it's and
of course has become amazingly relevant
today to a point where I read the paper
every day trying to figure out maybe
what what the ties are between John
Hutchins story and what's going on today
with domestic spying and civil liberties
but the newspaper back then everyone was
talking about this in August while all
this is going on right before Edward
Everett prints his article or submits
his his letter and in a New York paper
the New York ledger prints a list of
what they call secession journals this
is a list of a hundred and fifty four
piece papers they said these are papers
that oppose the Lincoln administration
they wrote the name of the newspaper and
the state that they existed in two weeks
later they printed a new list and this
included new titles for newspapers such
as suppressed mobbed died and there's
for example the Jeffersonian was
included on that the Christian Observer
was included on that in Philadelphia
this is a laundry list for the mobs to
visit these newspapers and when they
reprint that list two weeks later
there's 20 some-odd newspapers that have
already been mobbed or seized destroyed
in one way or another and they included
the rest and say well these are left you
guys really need to get on the ball
because there's still 130 papers out
there that opposed the war we need to
take care of this because the government
can't do it alone
so this was a huge issue back and forth
and like I said you have editors being
tarred and feathered
you have mobs carrying pistols we have
one instance where
a mob comes to a newspaper office and
the editors send out their daughter and
she disperses the mob because nobody
wanted to attack a woman so you have all
these amazing cases going on but yeah it
was the newspapers were talking about
and it terrified everybody they they
were talking about it but not as much
it's amazing that there really wasn't
much press censorship in the south of
course also the new paid newspapers
supported the war they supported the
South's efforts to break away from the
Union so there wasn't the dissension in
southern newspapers but they were very
proud of the fact that northerners were
opposing the war and they were trying to
take advantage of that you know with
Lincoln reluctantly signing this bill as
it gets out there maybe his cabinet
starts using it exploiting it expanding
the reaches of it he said you know
certain the newspapers were okay how can
we interpret this law now to shut down
these guys and was Lincoln looking at
this as like a runaway train he couldn't
stop it in some sense yes and there's
actually a second Confiscation Act
that's passed I believe in August of
1862 that replaces his first one and
actually gives a little more teeth but
this is a case where Lincoln's thought
as a necessary evil I think and he knew
what was going on he knew that civil
liberties were being suppressed but he
thought it was necessary to win the war
and he just kind of wanted to let it
play itself out as far as we could tell
at least and he doesn't make a lot of
specific statements regarding the
Confiscation Act we know that he
hesitated before he signed it because
the New York Times reported on it the
next day the New York Times which is
printing things like speech should only
be free when it's loyal so they're
saying these amazing things and then a
congressman also writes in his diary
that Lincoln was really conflicted on
whether or not to sign this bill but he
did sign the bill because he saw it as a
necessary evil
so those same lines I saw it quote in
your book where Lincoln being a lawyer
obviously had to realize you know what
he was doing was kind of running a
follow the Constitution and had to
experience a great deal of internal
turmoil and like you say hesitating when
he would sign things like the
confiscation act and there's a quote in
the book that sometimes to save a life
you have to cut off a limb and could you
elaborate on that that seemed like his
way of speaking by way of an analogy of
to save the Union you had to maybe
sacrifice some of the Constitution is
that what he meant by that yeah that's
absolutely what he meant sometimes you
have to you know the ends justify the
means
and that's kind of what he was going for
again an unprecedented war they were
kind of feeling their way through this
and Lincoln had this tremendous ability
to speak in absolutes when he gave his
address to Congress this was kind of a
laundry list explaining why he suspended
habeas corpus and how he put down the
mob in Baltimore in April but he just he
spoke in terms of black and white but
then he operated in a gray area and of
course most of the wars fought in this
gray area so we tend to look at these
great speeches that Abraham Lincoln
gives and say you know these are very
profound discussions that he's having
and that's true but then he's operating
in the middle and he's giving himself a
lot of leeway one way or the other and
he's looking to see how this is gonna
kind of work work its way out and of
course when when he were you when he ran
for reen amah nation in 1864 he thought
he was going to lose and so everything
that he'd been working for all these
years and his prosecution of the war he
thought was a complete failure and then
things started to turn around on the
battlefield and that's really where this
war was run was won or lost and the
Democrats started to take power again in
late 1862 early 1863 robert e lee is
starting to move his way north to make
his final stand at gettysburg in july
and that's where it falls apart for the
democrats
their success or failure no matter how
much political gain they're making is
really being determined on the
battlefield by the Confederate Army
you mentioned that you and your
co-author kind of disagreed on whether
or not link was right and kind of how he
handled things were there any other
issues that you had in researching or
writing this book you know with two
different personalities I guess trying
to write a book together I mean is there
anything else that came up well one of
the interesting things about the book
was how much research has changed during
the course of a 10-year project when we
started of course it was all time spent
at local historical societies at the
Library of Congress and that's one of
the interesting things about this book
is most of the time was spent at these
small historical societies reading
newspapers that nobody's touched in a
hundred and forty years so we wanted to
tell this new story from their own
perspective when we started it was all
done on site and now you're able to do a
lot of your preliminary research on the
Internet of course you're reading full
text of books you can do keyword
searching on the Abraham Lincoln papers
at the Library of Congress so that
changed a lot as far as just the
research side of it and I think one of
our benefits is that we looked at things
very different jeff is more politically
inclined and he likes to look at the
political advantages and disadvantages
of the situation where I look more I
think at the social side and I want to
know what John Hatchin was thinking I
want to get inside this guy's head and
find out what's motivating him is it is
it his religion his dad whether his
father was a Methodist preacher and what
effect did that have on his views how
did that affect his views on slavery
Jeff would look at more of the political
leanings of that and I'm interested in
the social side I want to know how this
affected his family life I want to know
how this affected his relationship with
his son who tried to be a little more
moderate at the beginning of the war and
pulled the paper away from this kind of
violent tempered John Hutchins editorial
and so there was differences as far as
that perspective goes but again I think
that makes the book stronger because you
do get all those points of view
when I was reading Lincoln's wrath I
guess I was a bit shocked because I
didn't realize how cunning and brilliant
he was especially when it came to
politics and you call them one of the
great media presidents thinking about
presidential studies and even the
president today or in the next
administration how often do you think
administration's look at Lincoln in this
side of his story to maybe think about
what's most important civil liberties or
the nation's security do you think that
this has an impact I think it absolutely
has an impact and I think I think all
presidents look to Abraham Lincoln for
guidance on civil liberties for guidance
on on how to how to get the support of
the people remember Lincoln went into
office with the lowest popular vote of
any US president so this is a guy who's
coming into office and he wasn't
everybody's hero he wasn't the savior of
the United States most people didn't
want him there and I think for
presidents to look at how to rally the
troops sort of say how to get public
opinion in your favor Lincoln didn't
have public opinion polls officially but
that's what the press was during that
time and Lincoln was a master
manipulator of the press he was not this
kind of oh gee shucks lawyer from
downstate Illinois who happened to be
elected president of the United States
he was writing anonymous editorials in
newspapers hey in Nicolay when he was in
office is writing anonymous editorials
editorials under pseudonyms in papers
throughout the North trying to get his
message out to the people before he's
elected Lincoln buys a German language
speaking newspaper in Springfield to
pass his message along to
german-speaking voters and when he's
elected president he quietly sells the
paper because that voting block is
important to him and he realized that's
how he's going to get his message across
so he did these sorts of things he's a
he's a master politician he's not a back
woodsman by this time he knows what he
wants
and he knows how to get it and he's
playing by the same rules that all the
other politicians are playing by so this
really shouldn't be a surprise
to anybody when we look at how complex
of a figure Abraham Lincoln was he was
just better at it I think is what it
boils down to in the end any other
questions anything on your mind okay
well thank you very much again for
coming